logs and exponential functions being
inverses of each other so when you graph
the inverse of a function
graphically what it is it's the
reflection over this line y equals x
this 45 degree line so if we reflect
this graph all over the line y equals x
what we get is the logarithm graph ok
the logarithmic graph and what you can
see here is that with the exponential
graph it gets closer and closer to the
x-axis this is an asymptote ok a
horizontal asymptote the log graph
though gets closer and closer to the
vertical asymptote the y axis okay so
the domain is X is greater than zero see
this graph here it's greater than zero
and it goes down to negative infinity it
keeps going up to positive infinity so
the range will be all real numbers
okay this graph goes up faster faster
the log graph goes up slower and slower
but it does keep going up to the right
there okay so let's look at some
specific examples now let's say we want
to graph y equals log base two of X
minus 1 plus 3 ok what does the 1 and
what does the 3 do to the log graph well
we know from other functions that this
graph is going to shift the graph 1 to
the right see it's the opposite of sign
if this was plus 1 to be 1 to the left -
when it's going 1 to the right 3 is
shifting up 3 ok and it's a log base 2
so what we're gonna do is excuse me
we're going to graph the the graph here
and we're gonna shift everything right 1
and up 3 ok so what I'm going to do
because this is an asymptote right here
this vertical asymptote is also going to
shift right 1 I'm gonna draw in that a
spittle right there this is the equation
x equals 1 that's the equation of that
vertical asymptote so right 1 up 3 I'm
gonna put a little open circle here this
is not necessarily a part of the graph
it's just
in a Little Helper okay little indicator
that we're gonna graph from this point
instead of the origin so now what we're
gonna do is we're going to look at the
parent function y equals log base two of
X and we're going to graph some some
points from here because it's been
shifted right one and up three now let's
take a look at this graph here so what I
would do okay is I would exponentiate
both sides of this equation so the log
base two and the exponential base two
those are inverses they cancel so now
what we have is let's write it over here
x equals two to the Y power okay so if
we make a table negative 1 is zero and
one two to the negative one is one half
because the negative takes reciprocal
anything to zero power is one and
anything to the first is two so what
we're gonna do is going to graph these
coordinates XY coordinates from this
point right here so we're gonna go right
a half okay down one right one up zero
right two up one so you can see this
graphs actually gonna go like this
there's our log graph that's been
shifted right one up three so now the
domain is going to be X is greater than
1 and the range is going to be all real
numbers because this goes down to
negative infinity up to positive
infinity okay so we'll do one more
example and we'll take a look at another
one so let's take a look here let's
erase this
[Music]
okay say for this example we want to
graph y equals log base 3 of X plus 2
minus 4 okay what do the 2 and the
negative 4 do to the graph left to see
the opposite left 2 down for this one
has the same effect as the sine this one
has the opposite effect of the sign so
this graphs going to shift left to
there's a vertical asymptote down 4 so
we're gonna think of that as our
starting point right there and now we're
going to focus in on the parent function
okay before the translation the parent
function we're going to exponentiate
both sides using the base 3 because
exponential functions and logarithmic
functions are inverses these are going
to cancel and we have 3 to the y equals
x so let's make a table
let's put substitute in for y instead of
4x so we've got 3 to the negative 1 0 1
& 2 that's 1/3 1/3 and 9 and if we plot
these points from here we've got 1/3 to
the right down 1 right 1 up 0 right 3 up
1 and right 9 up to over here okay so if
you see the graph it looks like like
that okay so the domain is X is greater
than negative 2 and the range is all
real numbers okay so that's the log
graph we'll take a look at some more
aspects of logs in the next video